hello everyone and welcome back to the
world rapid championship uh we are uh
going to show probably the most awaited
clash of the event magnus cross and
versus salire safiroja uh the player
that is uh well supposed to challenge
magnus for the title as you know uh some
time ago magnus said that he will not be
playing the world church championship
next cycle uh if alireza here doesn't
win the candidate so um quite a lot of
pressure on the 18 year old alireza
let's check out the game it's quite an
enjoyable one so magnus with the white
pieces opens with e4
we have c6 alireza goes for the karo
khan defense he's famous
for this by now d4 d5 and already here
on move 3 magnus started thinking and he
thought for about a move before deciding
on whether
where to go knight c3 knight to d2
whether to just capture where whether to
have three uh he goes e5 he goes for the
advanced variation of the karo khan
bishop to f5 and now uh c4 quite a rare
idea uh we have e6 and now knight to c3
we have knight to the e7 the bishop will
move and then the knight is coming to
this beautiful f5 square
and now magnus plays h3 now this is very
very rare and it's sort of a waiting
move you want to see what the black will
play knight to d7 while it is a knight
to f3 and now right there is a game
where uh d captures on c4 was played by
alireza plays bishop back to g6 uh
prepares knight f5 and it is now as of
move seven that we have a completely new
game
uh so let's see how magnus approaches
this we have b3 uh and already magnus
spent quite a lot of time here he's down
to some 11 minutes whereas
basically spent no time he has 14 and
something minutes so knight to f5 magnus
plays bishop to e2 and bishop to b4 now
developing the bishop with tempo the
knight here is undefended so bishop to
b2 uh and now both players castle so
castles castles uh and now f6
challenging the the central uh structure
magnus created here and magnus now
challenges the bishop on b4 and here is
the first time alireza started spending
some time he spent almost three minutes
on this uh
on his next move because uh you can't go
here you can't go here if you go here
this could be very tricky what if magnus
plays g for your knight will not be able
to retreat the e7 so it could be very
dangerous even though it's bad but you
will waste quite a lot of time which is
no doubt did for example bishop to e7 if
g4 uh you can even sacrifice this knight
here you can play f captures on e5 and
after g captures an f5 bishop captures
and black will have a very nice attack
against the white king uh but alireza
probably decided that maybe it's too
much he played bishop to a5 and now c
captures on d5 and here alireza went for
another deep thing thinking for over
five minutes which is uh basically a
third of his time in rapid time format
uh and um well do you capture with this
pawn or do you capture with this pawn
now in the end he decided to play c
captures on d5 uh both moves um are are
of course possible but he he just wanted
to
choose the one that makes the most sense
now this opens up the c file he can play
rook to c8 he will probably be able to
open up the center then maybe bishop can
come to c7 get the bishop on this
diagonal and so on uh magnus plays e
captures on f6 we have queen captures on
f6 and now rook to c1 alireza plays
knight to h4
uh challenges the knight on f3 and
magnus happily trades with knight
captures queen captures and now magnus
unlike some players
that we show on this channel knows the
power of the b4 move and he of course
plays pawn to b4
this
threatens the bishop and uh well where
do you put the bishop b6 or d8 are your
or your moves you do not want to put it
on c8 in front of the rook here uh so
bishop all the way back to d8 and now
bishop to g4 so this is what magnus got
out of the position he has a very strong
control over the c5 square he has a nice
nicely placed rook on the open c file
and he has the attack against the weak
e6 pawn this is a backward spawn and
magnus will now try to win it with moves
like queen e2 rookie one and he will try
and go after this pawn so bishop to f5
and now magnus captures it we have
bishop captures now you can't capture
with the pawn or the d5.4 so rook
captures nf5 and now queen eq magnus
continues the attack um on the weak e6
pawn knights the f8 this knight is now
an excellent defender of the pawn but
it's uh
not an excellently placed knight it
would be much better if this knight
could go for example to b6 here
and then you know it would just be an
excellent piece on c4 but for the moment
it's on f8 and now what do you play uh
well now magnus needs to get his knight
to e5 somewhere and from there it's
going to be a a monster knight now you
could do this for example via the a4
square i could play knight a4 knight to
c5 knight to d3 knight to e5 or magnus
decides it's better via d1 square
because after knight e3 you will attack
the rook so you will win one tempo while
uh maneuvering your knight so here
bishop back to b6 putting pressure on
the d4 pawn and here knight to e3 first
attacking the rook now where do you move
this rook uh wherever you move it it's
white will be able to attack it if you
move it to f7 just knight g4 to e5 will
go after the f7 rook if rook f6 knight
g4 already goes after the rook so
alireza tried rook to g5 but this allows
magnus to well just unleash all the fury
he plays f4 now attacks the rook here
rook to g3 and now magnus plays the
incredibly sneaky king to h2 he attacks
the rook with uh with his king and he's
preparing queen to f2 which will win the
rook you're not going to be able to get
out of this so alireza quickly goes back
rook to g6 and now
uh there are a couple of ways
you could play this position but there
is one very particular way uh that
should win you the game uh if you
continue uh
to play it like that so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the the
best move for white while i give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on playing uh well
either the immediate f5 or preparing it
with the g4 because uh both of them are
incredibly strong uh and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show uh
let's let's go with the g4 yeah it's not
about magnus the plate is just what i'm
gonna show you now what do you play here
uh well let's say you try h6 we're still
uh gonna go forward with f5 and now
after e captures on f5 knight captures
on f5 attacking the queen and well once
the queen moves there is no defense
against knight to e7 check
this will check the black king and also
win the rook here so there is really
nothing you you can do here and this
will be winning for white so this is one
way to do it but magnus decides that
it's also giving black a little bit too
much because uh for the moment black
doesn't have any threats and this knight
is a very strong piece so magnus first
goes knight to g4 he still wants to get
his outpost with knight to the e5 uh
queen back to d8 by alireza ended now a4
now preparing to further expand on the
queen side saying okay already you've
got nothing here on the king's side
bishop to c7 excellently placed as the
king is on h2 and now b5
we have bishop to d6 and now rook to c3
magnus now prepares to double up on the
c file rook to c8 and now rook captures
on c8 we have queen captures and finally
knight to e5 attacking the rook here so
rook to f6 alireza still not ready to
capture on e5 as that would really
uh really help magnus so rook to c1 now
attacking the queen queen to d8 and g3
now strengthening the f4 pawn and now
you will try to
do something on the queen side so here
rook to f5 and queen to d3 now uh and
here alireza plays g5 uh uh it is i had
the right idea although first you kind
of want to capture the knight here
bishop captures d captures and then g5
this makes sense and it will help you in
opening uh
well up uh some sort of an attack
towards the white king but he played g5
right away and this allows magnus knight
to g4 now threatening knight to h6 to
win the rook here on f5 so king to g7
and now knight the e3 attacking the rook
and the magnus is now down to four
minutes whereas alireza is already under
a minute so look back to f7 now comes f5
and here
it's not easy to play this see if you
capture this knight captures an f5 check
it's incredibly unpleasant for
for black
just uh a hard position to play so of
course you don't want to do this alireza
adds another defender he plays queen to
d7 and now magnus gets another attacker
rook to f1 with h6 uh but now king to g2
again a very unpleasant move getting the
king away from this diagonal so king the
g8 but now just knight to g4 now you're
threatening knight captures an h6 you
also have more control over the f6
square and there's just not a good move
for alireza here g7 was played king g7
now f6 check of course you cannot go uh
to g6 or h7 so king to h8 now magnus
just picks up the h6 pawn uh rooked h7
knight back to g4 and now queen the e8
trying to get some sort of a some sort
of an attack here but it's not going to
be easy we have bishop to a3 attacking
the bishop uh so bishop captures queen
captures and again the black queen
cannot move because the knight is
hanging here so queen to c8 trying to
get some sort of a uh counter idea with
queen to c to check but just rook to c1
forcing the black queen to move queen to
e8 now comes knight to e5 and it's
completely hopeless for alireza here
king to g8 we have queen to f3 magnus
could even push f7 right away but he
doesn't want to give up his knight for a
rook so just preparing it queen to f3
now comes queen d8 getting out of harm's
way and now rook to f1 adding more
pressure to the f file king to h8 now
comes queen e3 first magnus defends the
f6 pawn only now he goes after the g5
pawn so queen to c8 but magnus not even
allowing queen to c to check he plays
rook f2 now comes g4 already trying
everything to open up some uh lines but
magnus just plays h5 uh rook to h5 but
here just knight to f7 check and he was
in this position on mu 52 that alireza
firoja resigned to the game as there is
nothing more uh to be done here to give
you an example uh how the game might
continue let's say king g8 we're gonna
go knight d6 we're gonna attack the
queen and once the queen moves we're
gonna play f7 check and once the king
moves we're gonna play knight to e8 now
we're threatening knight f6 with this
monster fork everything will get worked
and you can to defend against everything
if queen is seven we still deliver this
fork king g6 knight captures uh and uh
for example if king captures we can just
play queen e5 check and you are getting
checkmated here king g6 you're gonna
play queen to h8 now prepare h5 and
there there really is no move here
knight h7 for example h5 checking h6
we're gonna play f8 queen and that's it
captures captures then i cannot move and
uh very quickly it's all going to be
over rook f6 check you're going to play
captures captures with check and now
after king g5 uh really anything or
maybe queen h4 will be checkmate so yeah
i know you guys enjoy it when i show you
how how the game might end so this is
one of the lines that could have
happened if the game continued but after
a knight f7 check all it is i resigned
and another incredibly important victory
for magnus carlsen who is now
on six points out of seven and i don't
know who or who else uh won in the uh
previous round who was on six points but
uh magnus is either uh winning a loan or
or sharing first place with someone for
the moment so we'll see what happens
next in the in the tournament uh but
alireza misses uh his chance here for
for a nice win against magnus uh so yeah
uh that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank uh czech
made epilepsy catherine matriarch jack
schroeder uh jeffrey radenor and david
kimura for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this amazing
tournament until it finishes uh thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day